we're at a point where 60 some odd
percent of Americans live and paycheck
to paycheck yeah in my early adult life
I live paycheck to paycheck I could
barely pay my rent that was for a number
of years I know what it's like it's not
fun
um we have the average American now has
54 000 in debt Biden inflation has cost
the average American household over ten
thousand dollars a year we can't afford
this on top of 37 trillion in debt
how quickly and what would you do to get
this economy turned around it'll go so
quickly number one I'm closing that
border like I had it we had the best
water ever
and by the way I think you all agree
we want people to come into our country
but we want them to come in Legally we
had a good system they were taking tests
we want people that love our our country
not people that want to blow up our
shopping centers and our Farms so we I
want people but I would make our borders
so strong and get off the criminals we
have many criminals in our country now
that weren't here three years ago I will
get them out ice
I will drill baby drill you know the
expression
you'll get energy way down when energy
comes down inflation's going to come
down hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else